what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch the next episode all
of us are dead episode seven today what
i asked right now was you take a bite
into that like button as always full
length watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code for all of us are
dead or over at our patreon page cover a
whole bunch of stuff over there special
thanks to all the become superior jacks
and of course the boys at prepper thanks
for helping us edit out these highlights
like that bite into you let's get to it
[Music]
speak of the devil
there might be students at the school
but let's start with them all
what a great shot god damn you're not
like all the other soldiers back at the
bow
that's why you're on the a-team
quarantine kid
[Music]
uh he'll be a special zombie
whoa
maybe that's why his son was like kind
of going back and forth for a bit
did he swim under water that whole time
he's been holding his breath since last
episode
[Music]
[Music]
he's going to misinterpret all this as
something sexual then
oh
buddy i thought he
made that pretty clear
i was gonna say just make it to him
perfect
people are going to think she's trying
to eat him though
[Music]
my man get that get that kiss
give her one back
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah that's what i'm [ __ ]
talking about man
so superpower
she if they have that level of super
hearing couldn't they hear
anyone
[Music]
[Music]
oh my
god
teach a girl to fish to eat forever that
looks like she ate a real fish
foreign
feed
[Music]
i don't know why that one was especially
gross yeah
well she knows what she's doing
maybe hamby's can't eat people
oh my gosh she's gonna grab his guts and
eat some more
then just vomit right into the cavity
oh she's gonna hear her in the closet
isn't she yeah that's what i thought she
first heard
[Music]
uh
damn
i want to get [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're not the boss anymore dude
[Music]
we're best friends man oh
what's up
now
gnarly
[Music]
street smarts bro
dude i'm riser secret out of here man
you just gotta
couldn't you skip the protocols at least
once
oh yeah
oh my god he's asian joel from the last
of us
all of the last of us are dead
now
this is the video game action episode
be the quiver my dude
that baby's just gonna be all taped
like a mummy baby
they are children
[Laughter]
excellent
[Laughter]
these two are my favorite odd couple
i i doubted for a second there
[Music]
[Applause]
he's that dedicated
hop in the chicken trunk
this guy's a really good guy he's the
best guy
we all deserve him looking for us in the
zombie apocalypse
oh
dude
well that holds
[Music]
and then i stabbed him in the eye
that is
reputation proceeds
go beat with your love
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that does not seem stable
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
work those pipes my guys
oh
in the end music's safe
that's crazy
god such cacophony
there's no way what they build could
stop that matter
oh
[Music]
[Music]
he's dead either way ah man this guy's
got ethics
which is all right
[Laughter]
children are the future education
knowledge is powerful
they haven't even thought about the
school
politeness fight do it just go
come on chung son go
please tell me you closed the door
sorry i gotta kill
god
how did they do some of this
so they didn't close the door
i'm the only one left
oh god damn it
yes
dude just just unlock the door
don't be an [ __ ] open the damn door
dude
dude
jesus christ open the god damn door
what the
dude that guy is pissing me off you
better open the goddamn door
oh jesus oh god
fire start a fire somehow
burn the zombies
[Applause]
dude open the door
open the door
all right
solid
good call
[Music]
this is so frustrating
i haven't been this upset in a while i
just want to scream at this kid
oh my god
wow
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
all right next time somebody has to cut
his head all the way off
[Music]
that's so frustrating
[Music]
no man i hate that guy
i can't decide if i hate the guy on the
roof more or if i hate queen anymore
yeah it's a great one it's a great
conundrum i'm not sure they both suck
yeah
jeez
then again like 99 of that school are
horrible people so you know it's just
yeah i'm out of the door with an [ __ ]
well yeah the problem is now if the door
gets open then guinom will inevitably
get onto the chopper and be saved
[Laughter]
alrighty yeah wow
man that uh last few minutes
i was like i know they're not gonna open
that door and so on [ __ ] the
cliffhanger they're gonna do that
cliffhanger [ __ ] yeah next episode
door's gonna fly right open
a lot of this theme dealing with uh the
bullied
getting their their their payback even
in some ways guinom is bullied maybe
bullying begets bullying maybe yeah
maybe the worst bully is the bully who's
like number two to the main bully who
gets bullied by the bully and then
becomes an even bigger bully because
yeah and then the ultimate bullied oonji
will now become
the master bully
killing everybody yeah wow that's that's
gnarly snarly stuff
so all right we got prez prez oh we got
okay lee sue
and what's perez's name ramcha no uh no
namra nam ram jam ram bruh wow
[Music]
stud muffin perez all out in the open
now i like them
confessing their feelings to each other
for some reason i was under the
impression that she like really
did you that he made it clear already
then i was looking back on that
headphone scene and i realized oh he
never actually said something did he no
no he's just putting vibes out i could
have sworn he like made it clear in that
scene and his whole time watching it
under the
under the optics that he's already
established his feelings for her like
we'd know but i thought he i thought she
already knew
so yeah that was really sweet scene and
now we're just building up some stuff
that has to pay off i like i like going
back to the quarantine zone where you're
seeing like okay
some of these soldiers are
not bad people like even the main guy in
charge who comes across like an ominous
douchebag when he's tall and talk to
assembly member woman about how she
won't get special privileges but he's
just being disciplined he's just being
stern but you can see he's a caring guy
still a little bit surprised the uh
oblivious nature of not even checking on
schools
obviously yeah
for that to be like the last thought on
everyone's mind i think is interesting
we haven't been anywhere near those
places yet sorry you mean the buildings
where there's hundreds to maybe
thousands of students the future
yeah we're just assumed that they were
all dead
you know the worst place to go is to a
school because think about it the kids
are already there if the outbreak
happens near there then it's just gonna
be overrun right away there's no point
even trying to go to school i think this
all started from a school too yeah that
was the last place they checked even the
schools bullying
yeah the students are going to stand up
to the soldiers at the end that's that's
what this is all about damn that's
that's embarrassing that's cool getting
the caring side what i think this show
does really well
is doing a splice
of like pretty much every type of zombie
property i've ever seen like that and
but in a way that enhances
uh expands upon and and i think um
compliments and and sure it shows it
wears its love for the zombie genre on
his shoulder i think that's one of the
great things about it is it knows how to
be like a cool zombie show when you're
going to like the pob and the action
action-driven moments like there's a lot
more action in this episode than i think
some previous episodes they're more than
just like thank god this wasn't boring
yeah
um i think we're past that part of when
people said it was so yeah that like
this this uh like with the pov of the
gun play at the top of here
uh seeing firefighting dad breaking in
grabbing some weapons shocking and some
people you know or like getting on your
bikes and heading out like there's some
real action moments here that i thought
were really cool like i think like the
love for the horror the action and then
realizing like how the zombie rules
really work and then also like taking
full advantage of it and watching those
sequences unfold like when the students
are creating this little barrier and
using sound to bait the zombies into
their room and the way they
did that's think about the extras and
the background players and how
uncomfortable of a situation that is
every horde scene i find myself thinking
okay now how many of these bodies to the
bottom of the frame must be dummies in
order for them to be crawling all over
each other and like it just it appears
as though
i have no idea how a half of or most of
these extras aren't getting injured
seriously every time it looks like they
would be and i think that's part of the
appeal of the physicality that they
realize here
uh so
i'm enjoying that quite a lot and also
uh you know when it comes to
even uh guinom like i i really liked his
scene
a lot uh you know like it gave me a
different appreciation for the character
yeah when
it's i'm not gonna say he's a bully he's
definitely not a bully because that
guy's mean to him
i'm just saying that
that there's it at least gives an
indicator of something hurt and lost
within him as a child yeah
that would allow him to succumb to this
other guy who's really like shorter than
him and like allows himself to be
intimidated by this dude but
i kind of forgot that that other guy
calls the shots yeah yeah in that moment
i had to be like oh right that's their
power dynamic and it makes it so
sinister i you you said this last week
and i think it is important to touch on
is as much as that is a hateable
character that guy's performances are
[ __ ] great because too just the way
that he has this very sort of like
almost lackadaisical way of looking at
everybody like he's so like just sort of
like calm and observant in the way he
like has to be coaxed into crawling
under and you watch the gears turn and
you watch him like play with this guy
you know and and it's it's funny because
you know it to me it drew me in and i
was like was this what he was going to
do all along or is this more because
he's realizing at this moment like nah
dude i don't i don't need i don't have
any kinship with you left from the
before times i i'm totally above you as
he says now well i think he's taking his
power
like really this ever since he got
turned he's been
all about mass consuming and taking back
power from wherever he felt power was
stripped from him taking out the
principle you know looks at his eye he
wants to use it has really offered
chong's son
and he now that the guy who called the
shots when they're in the little
bullying gang that they had
so
i like the way they they brought i like
i really like the way they handle him
and and i think it's really cool where
you have
stud muffin and chong son at the very
end there when the prior you have a
scene
where they are talking about guinam and
then because because chong songs could
have sworn guinom died and then
stunned muffin saying you know no i saw
him die he fell off the floor and then
they're both dealing with the
realization of oh [ __ ] this is
worse than hey like we're both right
we're both right and we're both way
wrong
this guy is
worse than all them and then i sure i'm
sure it creates some level of conflict
too
i i feel like there's so many different
directions it can go with the situation
like that of and like i said i don't
want to get too bogged down in
theorizing with the show that we're just
kind of going through really fast
because you know my mind starts to jump
to the idea of like well
when you're presenting something like
that like maybe this guy has a cure that
we got to utilize so we can't just try
to kill him there's a lot of maybe we're
going to keep him alive like i feel like
there would be some type of debate
uh so yeah just kind of leave it at that
because i'm sure we'll get that answered
in like five minutes in the next episode
so but it does make me really curious
and especially because you have this
this triangle of people with that gene
of like the only you have i love the
polar uh sort of opposites that yoonji
and guinom are because you know even
though in social
situations they are literally the
opposite it almost makes you wonder if
that gene
is somehow linked to just a certain
sense of anguish or something because
you know maybe not
as much with nom robert those are two
like very tortured characters who are
now
being at polar opposites of the human
social spectrum are now sort of in the
same plane
which is just fascinating to me but um
yeah yeah that's true and also i'd say
with uh omg i i like how she's coming
into uh this like new level of revenge
and confidence
as well like she could just take all
these people out and i'm so glad our
main players were but it kind of goes
back to
like her character is the living
formation of what science dad who
created all this
was uh
kind of motivated by you know like i was
about to say out loud that the students
at least didn't bully on ji but then
they were also complicit in the nature
of they never they never did anything
yeah they never intervened they never
really tried to help so by its
association
but the transitive property of this
it would stand to reason that like no
one matters to her anymore you know
and
then yeah with namra you're a it's
i'm curious with the level of
consciousness is on this because clearly
they have this like
enhanced
sensory experience perhaps with
they really established it with hearing
they didn't really establish it with
i mean with like
yeah maybe it talks about about oh no
she doesn't smell like nothing i've ever
smelled before that's true that's true
yeah but it seems like the most
persistent is the sound yeah so it's
it's to me i'm like well now you could
use her to like navigate your way
through
like everywhere she's gonna snuck out
using her stuff
yeah you guys alright go yeah i'm gonna
snuck out if you if she learned to you
know hewn
i said the word he did
her abilities
so
my curiosity though is like what is the
level of
logic
or awareness that can override
desire like will she still get filled
with a need to feed
and then have to just give in to that or
can she just like talk herself out of
doing something you know yeah like so it
can can it be overridden with enough
willpower and and what is the need to
feed in that state because there's at
least that one bit where yunji like
pukes up all that guy
all of the guy she just ate but not the
fish
well it seems like with this new
um
this new hybrid or enhanced human
discussion that my mind's starting to
think like okay is this show headed down
a path of like they're purging the world
and there'll be a new breed of humanity
just yeah super sensory humans who are
are semi-bloodlusty well they talked
about the white blood cells too so
they're giving indication that there
could be a a version of curing this to
some extent
and they are the three the the few white
blood cells yeah the answers are all in
that school they are they really are so
many of the answers the laptop the
origin of the outbreak yeah you know
yeah the potential literally everything
is there
pretty soon they're gonna get to a dead
end with their soldier guy and they're
like [ __ ] we gotta go back to the school
which i i really appreciated those poor
trails to like that guy like he just
chose to go out and help and and yeah
for as much like the system fails us
commentary as there has been i enjoyed
this episode brought at least some
around of like okay they are actually
going to the school okay they are
actually kind of coming up with in the
moment reasons
for why their protocol is what it is
based on the situation here now
versus you know in the previous episodes
so much has been about you know like
these are the protocols that we all
adhere to in normal society
and you know
yeah i i feel like this is
what being the third day
now or still maybe the second day like
it all feels like the the way they keep
an eye on like the geography of the
progression of this whole situation the
way they choose to cut around is really
conscientious and just to go back to
something you said at the beginning like
i i do love the way that they'll take
you can tell that there's love for the
zombie genre throughout this because one
of my favorite aspects of the show's
style is that it will throw in various
things
that
will slip past you with and then in
moments you'll go oh that is like a
classic zombie moment or classic zombie
movie trope but they're so good at
taking that love and then completely
infusing it with exactly what they're
doing here so it only
in the moment it just feels like it's of
the piece and you realize oh wow there
is like so much of the lexicon of zombie
stuff in here and even breaching into
video like this episode a ton of video
game stuff like when he's in the
uh aside from like the mall shootout
sequence in the beginning like even when
firefighter dad is in the police station
i was like this is just like a resident
evil game you know you gotta like open
the cabinet and like you know you got
zombies bursting in like they're they're
really good at yeah spreading it around
and never feeling like oh this is one
show and this is another show like they
all feel really well unified yeah very
true
and then uh we got the cop guy too cop
guy and the influencer reminds a copy
reminds me a lot of my uncle danny
shouts out to my uncle danny dude looks
a lot like him and uh yeah i really love
him a lot because he he come he can when
he first introduced him he really came
across like some hard ass dude who
and he is but he didn't he i just never
expected that the more you hang out with
him the more just like he really cares
about saving people
so much like he is the best guy because
which is yeah no keep it nice you got it
no because that's such a like it's such
a great juxtaposition from how they uh
introduced him because because even
though you know dad dad is responsible
and thus loses certain amounts of
sympathy you are really pitted to expect
him to be an antagonist
at the outset and and yeah it's like
looking back on that ideological debate
it's like oh yeah maybe i was the wrong
guy to have that debate with because
this does seem like one of the good ones
out there this guy
you know
and it makes sense that the other guy
seoul university would abandon him
they set that up like a gazillion times
that he was just on his way to not be
with him
even though cop guy saved him yeah
some gratitude you guys some gratitude
but like dude seoul university you can't
take care of
[ __ ] the little girl and the baby
you're too weak well that was the other
thing i was like he just he just sped
off and i'm like what is he just gonna
like toss the baby toss the girl and go
or shove the girl in the trunk and go
and they did confirm the mom is dead for
chong son
yeah that sucked
the special zombie jeans for her that's
too bad you thought the chicken in her
blood that's never her
msg
shields you from the disease
unfortunately not
but here we are that was really that was
really well well done i think every one
of these episodes is good the dislike
any one of these episodes this is a
great zombie movie
it is great really long zombie movie no
they expand it out and then every time
they like cut to a new character they're
kind of adding in
a new zombie type of movie is what
they're doing that love for zombie genre
shows they're like really throwing like
they don't just start off like let's try
to establish a bunch of different zombie
movies at first
they they really like whenever you cut
to a different character they have a
different kind of zombie movie yeah and
i think that's really cool that they are
doing that and i like that they even
included the evolution of a human
zombie hybrid or hobby or how they call
it you know being like if you want to go
all out and get some like zombie
creatures maybe not in this season i
don't know how far they'll go but i feel
like if they does get another season
like yeah dude like the crazy zombie
creatures now like
yeah another full monster route why not
it's good
dogs zombie birds yeah bio creatures
they they can't you might as well they
introduced a zombie rat that was like
the start of this whole thing so let's
go all out all right guys well that's it
for today thank you so much for being
here uh leave a like if you can and last
but not least we'll send this off with a
paper
deontay w
tongue punch fart box i think you know
why you're getting the shout out today
we got not one but two close-ups on
people's fart boxes in this episode a
lot of uncomfortable sounds and i
couldn't help but imagine to myself we
were trapped with deontay how much more
of that will we have to hear day in and
day out constantly trying to tolerate
you not throw you out to the zombies
maintain our humanity but then halfway
through what happens oh [ __ ]
we found the solution what can the
zombies not take more than the absence
of human flesh an abundance of sulfuric
fart fumes from your fart box my friend
and that's the secret that's the
solution you've saved us all and here we
were about to throw you out to your
death so deontay thanks for keeping it
real out there thanks for holding it
down and i hope you're having a good
2022 so far all the love and stay
farting
[Music]